das ist wirklich mal wieder papieren zum
ersten mal wurde ein derartiges bild von
den jets eines schwarzen lochs gemacht
und schon ist wieder alles anders als
gedacht der jet ist viel größer als
vermutet und das stellt zumindest mal
wieder einige theorien in frage und wie
bei dem erwarteten bild von sagittarius
a stern ist hier ein absolutes
riesenteleskop zum einsatz gekommen dass
alle rekorde bricht jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
es war ein wirklich riesiges
radioteleskop nötig um dieses bild zu
machen
dazu wurden mehr als 20 radioteleskope
weltweit zusammen geschaltet und dazu
noch das weltraum radioteleskop
radioastronomie mit einem 10 meter
reflektor zusammen haben diese teleskope
achtung einen durchmesser von 355.000
kilometern
das ist nahezu die entfernung zwischen
erde und mond und die aufnahme die das
teleskop jetzt gemacht hat ist auch
absolut irre denn was hier zu sehen ist
hat das forschungsteam absolut nicht
erwartet es geht um das zentrale
supermassereiche schwarze loch in der
galaxie ngc 12 75 befindet sich im
perseus galaxienhaufen der etwa 230
millionen lichtjahren entfernung
diese galaxie ist als seifert galaxie
klassifiziert das bedeutet dass sie ein
aktives schwarzes loch hat das sich
derzeit von umgebende material ernährt
dieses schwarze loch befindet sich in
der frühen phase der erzeugung massiver
jets und das bild zeigt etwas völlig
unerwartetes zitat es stellte sich
heraus dass die beobachtete breite des
jets deutlich größer war als bei den
derzeit favorisierten modellen wo der
jet aus der ergo sphäre des schwarzen
lochs entsteht ein raum gebiet direkt
neben einen sich drehenden schwarzen
loch in das der raum selbst zu einer
kreisenden bewegung um das loch
geschleppt wird sagte der hauptautor
gabriele giovanni vom italienischen
nationalen institut für astrophysik auf
dem bild ist das loch oben in den grünen
fleck und der jet ist alles was er nach
unten aus wirft er hat eine länge von
achtung drei lichtjahren und dürfte ein
bis zwei lichtjahren breit sein und das
ist viel breiter als bisher angenommen
bisher sagt es ja in den animationen und
grafiken der nasa zum beispiel eher so
aus
kurz zur erklärung die ergo sphäre um
ein schwarzes loch ist die zone in der
ein rotierendes schwarzes loch wie bei
einem strudel im wasser alles mit in
seine drehbewegung mit nimmt auch den
raum nichts kann sich dieser bewegung
entziehen auch wenn diese zone noch
nicht hinter dem ereignishorizont liegt
bisher war man davon ausgegangen dass
dieser diese zone die quelle auch der
jets ist aber
dieser dead hier der sieht ganz anders
aus statt dessen zitat könnte dies
bedeuten dass zumindest der äußere teil
des jets von der viel größeren
akkretionsscheibe die das schwarze loch
umgibt ausgeht dass sagt thomas sowohl
einen von der alte universität in
finnland und leiter des radio ist von
beobachtungs programms noch ist das
forschungsteam aber nicht sicher was
dieses bild wirklich bedeutet unser
ergebnis entkräftet noch nicht die
aktuellen modelle in denen die jets aus
der atmosphäre gestartet werden aber es
gibt den theoretikern hoffentlich einen
einblick in die jets struktur in der
nähe des abschlusses um die modelle zu
entwickeln
das sagt ja wohl einen so oder so wird
man sich gedanken über die jets und
deren entstehung machen müssen ich bin
auf die ergebnisse sehr gespannt wenn er
als erstes neues zum thema schwarze
löcher und deren jets und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
hättet hier meine telefonnummer bei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen andern vom neuesten video
garantiert und zur begrüßung da gibt es
ein kleines goodie einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
das rätsel der supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann